you
if you were to open up my computer and
look at the list of bookmark websites on
Google Chrome you'd see a bunch of the
usual suspects Google Maps I'm a sports
nut so ESPN is on there I like a key
weather to get weather updates but you'd
also see a much more offbeat a link
there simply titled film how it all got
started and you might conclude from that
that while I guess Joe's quite a film
buff but that's actually not the case I
mean III like movies I like movies quite
a bit but I I didn't even take
cinematography or whatever backward I
was in school and you wouldn't quite
call me a film buff actually the reason
why this website is on that list is that
the story absolutely fascinates me and
despite the fact that it's over a
hundred years old I continue to find it
incredibly relevant to today how many of
you ever heard of the film The Great
Train Robbery it's quite a revolutionary
film even though it's it's really short
I think it might be twelve or fourteen
minutes something like that but it
really completely revolutionized in
industry before the Great Train Robbery
films were shot from a single wide shot
camera position while actors paraded in
front of the camera a stage play on film
now to many of us the fact that the
producers and creators of the Great
Train Robbery
could see that there were other
possibilities that you could cut and
edit that you could have one scene you
could have kind of the passengers kind
of having a good time on the train and
then you could cut to the bad guys as
they scheme what they're going to be
doing and then you could do a close-up
on the faces of the bad guy or the
close-ups of the the normal people on
the train that all seems pretty
self-evident to us but up until the
point when
the Great Train Robbery was created an
entire industry didn't see that the
creators of the grain trauma or train
robbery saw that possibility that an
entire industry was blind to now one of
the most amazing parts of the story to
me is this next part is that even after
the Great Train Robbery came out the
vast majority of the industry still
could not let loose of their previous
paradigm I love this quote during the
early days of film some producers
resisted the use of close-ups arguing
that they had paid for the whole actor
so they wanted to see the whole actor at
all times
now you can't make this stuff up now we
find that incredibly funny but we find
it funny because we we know how the
story ended but there are certain people
who really had a tremendous vision for
what film could be we understand this
kind of perspective the motion picture
today is the greatest medium of
expression the world's ever known
capable of giving life in form to all
ideas practical and emotional its only
limitation is human ingenuity great
quote probably summarizes most of our
view about film today it's really pretty
amazing medium it's kind of fun to watch
the Oscars on Sunday night and see
everything that's going on in the world
of film lately
the interesting thing though about this
guy John sites who's the cinematographer
quoted is that he made that quote back
in 1930 he saw these possibilities and
even went so far as to say hey there's
possibilities here that I haven't even
thought of yet
he was one of those visionaries who
could see things while an entire
industry was still blind to them and as
a consequence he went on to get seven
Academy Award nominations so what you
might ask does this all have to do with
entrepreneurship
well I contend very simply that
entrepreneurship is then
entrepreneurship at
Center builds off tectonic shifts and
tectonic shifts that create
opportunities for people to see things
that entire industries are blind to the
film industry is just one example but I
think we continue to see example after
example today and quite honestly this
relates very much to Pandora by the way
before I talk about the Pandora piece I
also contend that we live in a world
today of accelerating pace of tectonic
shifts I think if one were to look at
the pace of history than the number of
these tectonic shifts that came along
you know the the periodicity of them was
much much greater in terms of the number
of years we're being hit over and over
again we look back on the rollout of the
Internet as ancient history
20 years ago and say hey since then
we've had even greater changes global
warming changes the development of the
human genome the development of mobile
broadband wireless as I'll talk about
creates even new possibilities on top of
the wired broadband so I think what that
means is that the opportunities for
entrepreneurship are greater today and
will be greater in the future than they
ever have before because these tectonic
shifts are accelerating but the key is
to see these possibilities while others
are blind to them so back to the Pandora
part of this story it was is pretty
early in the process of Pandora when I
read this quote this quote is from the
CEO of one of the great big radio
conglomerates radio in this country as
may know is highly consolidated by Henry
knees like Clear Channel and CBS and I
won't name the specific individual or
company but this is a quote that they
made I don't know probably six seven
years ago at this point and the quote
was I like the Internet it's like
another broadcast tower for our stations
or put another way I love film
it's another way for me to distribute my
stage plays
we very much disagreed with this view of
the internet in fact let me kind of walk
through kind of the foundation of our
thinking that underlay kind of our look
at the world that turned out to be a
little different from how the existing
industry looked at it some really basic
stuff we grew up in a world that was
really dominated by broadcast media I'm
old enough I can remember that really
there were three dominant television
networks back in the 60s and 70s and
tens of millions of households tuned in
each evening and listened to you know
Walter Cronkite and his successors and
Huntley and Brinkley and their
successors and all of America
experienced a very small set of content
delivered the same way at the same time
to tens of millions of people
that's the broadcast world and music
people would listen to the top 40
countdown on Sunday by Casey Kasem or
his ultimate successors it was a
broadcast world which is one too many
in one way in fact still as far as we've
come the vast majority of media content
in the world today is still consumed off
of this model along comes the internet
which is fundamentally different and
again I realize this is really basic but
I contend that it's tremendously
powerful this diagram on the left like
kind of like I just found in doing a
google search and it's from some NYU
course on the technology the Internet
and it's just scribbles you know unicast
and makes the point that in it on the
internet there's one stream poor client
a unique characteristic of the Internet
is that every single one of us when we
connect has a unique connection there
literally is no advantage on the
Internet to sending the same set of bits
to multiple people you literally have to
send them multiple times one for each
user anyway so it's a unicast medium
that is
one-to-one and importantly it's two-way
all right so that's incredibly basic
forgive me for that but I contend that
those characteristics change everything
and the one-to-one nature of the
internet enables personalization I know
there was a panel earlier today on the
personalized web
I don't think personalization is just
some one random thing that people have
happened to take advantage of in the
internet it is one of the most
fundamental things that the internet
revolution enables because the
Internet's one-to-one and second the
two-way nature of the internet enables
all sorts of Ko something's and I think
people are continuing to find even more
and more ideas in terms of Ko
something's cause on the co-creation
community conversation competition
Commerce in fact I might go so far as to
say if you look at the big winners
they're really big winners from the
first wave of the the Internet all of
them in in in very basic ways took
something that pre-existed the Internet
and updated it had the vision to see
what others were blind to updated it
using these two capabilities the
internet Google in many ways is just a
directory in fact if you know the
history of the web the early dominant
player in something akin to search was
Yahoo but Yahoo was a great big
directory in computer terms it was just
this great big tree it were just you can
drill deeper and deeper and deeper and
deeper and maybe you could actually find
what you what you ultimately wanted
Google came along turned that whole idea
on its head and said forget this whole
directory thing that's a little bit like
the broadcast model how about you tell
us the web site what you're looking for
and I'll create a personalized directory
for just what you're what you're after
so this happens to be a search for
iPhone Bluetooth headset I happen to be
searching for an eyetooth an iPhone
bluetooth headset and in essence what I
get is a personalized directory on just
the topic that I want
incredibly basic you say but again I
think that's really the the cornerstone
of what Google did is take this concept
directory personalize it and then take
advantage of the fact that the community
could rank using the PageRank algorithm
of Google and and make that directory as
useful as possible Facebook which has
become many things and it is an
extraordinary piece but at his core
started by taking the idea of a college
Facebook and bringing to it
personalization and community eBay is
basically one of the most old-fashioned
you know oldest fashion concepts there
is it's a flea market but they took the
concept of flea market and added
personalization in this case I was
searching for a very specific disc by a
late Renaissance early baroque composer
named Heinrich schütz I was looking for
this for my brother's Christmas present
of all things who likes choral music and
in essence what I got is a flea market
of purveyors of the music of heinrich
schütz and the other interesting thing
is that eBay always used community to
solve one of the biggest problems in the
flea market world which is can I trust
this seller gosh it's just kind of this
this fly-by-night booth that I'm up
against how do I know whether it's
trustworthy or not and eBay very smartly
solve that with community rankings
Amazon in many ways I find one of the
most amazing stories in all of the the
kind of big first generation internet in
that it's just a mail-order catalog I
mean we add it's at its core and
mail-order catalogs have been around for
almost a century
I mean Sears Roebuck started as a
catalog when Amazon started there were
tons of mail-order catalogs in this
country run by presumably smart
intelligent people but none of them had
the vision that Jeff Bezos had
and remarkably they're all pretty much
dead and gone there's still some niches
in the mail-order catalog world but he
really took the concept of mail-order
catalog personalize it again ratings are
tremendously important I could just go
right I didn't have to kind of page
through I could do a search and I
actually found this CD that I was
looking for it's a little mind-boggling
if you actually look at that that price
of that was a hundred and thirteen
dollars it's really good choral music
and I like my brother a lot so I did buy
it for him and really took advantage of
community and obviously commerce and
Amazon is a tremendous behemoth
obviously as a result of this so so
again if you tie this back to Pandora
you know what's what's the key central
under insight that underlies Pandora's
well there's this thing called radio
that's been around since 1920 still
listened to by hundreds of millions of
people in this country billions of
people around the world but it operates
in a broadcast model it's one way it's
one too many
we brought the observation being people
who are very passionate about music but
the interesting thing about radio is yes
it's this kind of broadcast model which
drives you to kind of vanilla chocolate
strawberry kind of offerings but music
is intensely personal it's incredibly
diverse as a category it's intensely
personal and so it is made for this
personalization potential that the
internet enables and that we could
actually using the intellectual property
hat we had in essence enable our users
to co-create their experience the
experience would be unique to them and
because of the opportunity for feedback
that they literally could co-create
their experience so you might say Joe
that's all great and fine and well and
good I might mention by the way that
it's not quite as simple as having this
set of ideas obviously people at Google
and Amazon had to execute very well as
well but there is I contend a foundation
core
in sight of vision that's based on
seeing things that others are blind to
that is at the very core of the success
of all of those entities and we fall
someone in the same bucket but you still
might come back and say you know that's
all fine and good wonderful explanation
in the past in the rearview mirror and
heck we're trying to be entrepreneurs
now haven't all the great opportunities
been taken and to that I contend even in
my film saga which is basically a
century old there are still people who
have extraordinary vision and are seeing
possibilities that others are blind to
the creators of Avatar are just one
incredible example one might say
inception in many ways inception one a
whole bunch of cinematography Awards
Sunday night because it brought new
concepts to film that really had never
quite been done before so there's still
plenty of opportunity even in these
categories for visionaries who see
opportunities that others are blind to
in some cases for example the
development of animation which really
the the as I understand it the creators
of Avatar waited four years for the
technology to catch up so that they
could put together some of their
concepts that they knew the technology
would ultimately enable that they could
actually bring them to life in film I
want to talk a little bit about mobile
which is a little bit closer to today
all of us in this room might be so kind
of forward-thinking leading-edge that we
think mobile is old news but I would say
we are very much still in the early
phases of feeling the impact of what
mobile broadband connectivity does for
us and in many ways I think there's
there's some people who approach mobile
and say well it's just the Internet it's
just you know the Internet and so it's
not really you know quite the
breakthrough of mobile of broadband
wireless in its fixed form but III do
think that
and I'll talk about some examples that
the cornerstone element of mobile
broadband wireless that it is with you
as simple as that sounds is has already
been the basis for insights by visionary
entrepreneurs that have been able to
create significant new opportunities as
a consequence of that
so obviously the things that I talked
about before are still relevant but I
think the with you part changes lots of
things and I don't pretend to know and I
would I actually believe the list of
sorry about that the list of
possibilities that are simply a function
of the with you part is still exploding
clearly location-based opportunities are
there you can see all of those
developing one I must admit that I
completely missed even as this was
developing maybe I'm just been too busy
during this period is is simply the
opportunities for time killing that are
a function in the fact that the device
is is with you a few examples again I
think Google folks do an extraordinary
number of things well they were among
the very first to kind of modify their
app it's kind of an interesting story if
you go to the original iPhone when apps
first came out Google had an application
that was pre-installed was Maps Yahoo an
application had an implication that was
pre-installed there was weather
the Yahoo weather application was
completely unchanged sorry about that
completely unchanged from what Yahoo
weather was on the web
it's just Yahoo weather which is useful
in itself but the interesting thing is
right beside it from Google was the
Google Maps application who'd added this
you know and this wonderful little thing
in the lower-left that when you press on
it tells you where you are and anything
many of us have experienced just that
simple little capability
has dramatically changed the utility to
device opentable is a really interesting
story I don't know if any of you have
heard Jeff juror than the CEO of open
table talk about mobile and OpenTable
they they actually did not move quickly
on this one they weren't originally sure
it would have much applicability but
then they focused on the fact that
there's a new capability that could be
brought to open table which is to not
simply make a restaurant reservation but
to make a rest reservation that's near
you and when they brought this so find a
table that that's nearby based on your
location they found an incredible
adoption of of their mobile app and I
think it now represents something like
twenty or twenty five percent of all the
reservations that are made on an open
table and is the most important growth
element of their business and then
there's bubble wrap put this in the
category of things I didn't have the
vision to see I'm clearly in the blind
two category here but this application
gets a lot of use on my iPhone and it
has to do with the time killer thing in
that time period between you get to the
rest on you order the food and you're
waiting for it arrive you have a major
kind of time killing element I have two
daughters and one of their favorite
things to do in that time killing moment
is to pummel dad once again at
bubble-wrap I have never beaten them at
bubble-wrap I guess Mike I keep saying
my fingers are too big but it's
interesting again in the sense that the
truth is the the iPhone and other
devices have become tremendously
powerful gaming devices in some cases
those those games today take advantage
of connectivity in other cases they
don't I think we'll certainly see more
and more of the devices taking advantage
of connect
in the context of games but again the
people who got out in front of this or
people who had the vision to see
possibilities based on what this new
tectonic shift in mobile wireline
broadband mobile wireless broadband
enabled so what's wrong with this
picture
it gives the same old book in the new
format or put another way before iBooks
to be invented
we're simply pictures of the original
pages of a paper book displayed
statically on a screen a digital copy of
a paper book imagine what a book
actually could transform itself into and
some of you may know there have been
people who've been playing around with
this and but I contend that that even if
you're aware of those which are kind of
bringing in some visual elements imagine
what the possibilities really could be
here in the context of a book on
something like an iPad yes not only are
there opportunities for it to be
non-static for there to be live video
and interactive elements in it perhaps
there are even opportunities to to have
different endings for different people
you might be part of a group that in
some sense the the what's what's a book
when it's combined with a massively
multiplayer online game in which the
book itself changes and morphs as you go
through the experience I'm not
contending that's the greatest idea on
the planet but I think it's an
interesting illustration and
particularly in the context of you know
a little bit of a contest between Kindle
which is phenomenal phenomenal device
but in some sense is deeply invested in
the concept of the electronic book is
pretty much the digital version of the
static paper book and what a book might
be in terms of the much more capable
devices that are out there in terms of
iPads and other forms of tablet
computing I think it'll be really
interesting to watch and see
what what is a book there's certainly
there's going to be four decades books
in their conventional form you know
delivered on electronic devices but
where might creative people go in terms
of what what iBooks or electronic books
enable so as this conference wraps up
and I suspect we have a room full of
entrepreneurs to be in here the question
I would leave you is what do you see
that all the rest of us are blind to
thank you all very much it's really a
pleasure being with you I hope you've
enjoyed the conference a great deal
so we'll take some questions now on
questions on this questions on anything
else except IPOs and s ones and things
like that I feel I Pio is kind of in the
hands of God in the sec at this point
that so others freshmen comments the
question is how is Pandora different
from Spotify and in Spotify is a great
product they've done some terrific work
Spotify is best at kind of when you know
what you want and you want to hear it on
demand you know that's what it's good at
so you know if you have to hear you know
the new Lady Gaga track born that way
and you need to hear it now
Pandora's a really crappy place to get
that experience and Spotify is a good
place to get that yeah
I'll continue on from from there what we
focus on is that important period of
time when you want someone else to play
DJ when you want a serendipitous
experience when you want discovery etc
and that's what we seek to do better
than anyone else in the world the
Spotify guys do a great job with kind of
a nun demand kind of client build your
own playlist even share that that
playlist so there's kind of we're trying
to solve somewhat different not not
180-degree different problems but
somewhat different problems the second
part of the question was how do we have
a better business and again I actually
don't see ourselves competing with
Spotify so I don't necessarily feel I
have to in some way diss their business
to feel good about ours I think there's
room for both to succeed what we like
about our business is that the majority
of the time music is unique as
form of entertainment and it's most
frequently consumed in the background
that's one of the key observations that
underlies how Pandora works and that you
can do lots of things if you lean
forward create stations thumbs up skip
etc but Pandora is also designed to work
for you while you're doing other things
your heads in a spreadsheet you're
cooking you're driving you're partying
whatever and what that means because
music is primarily consumed in the
background is that our market
opportunity is probably bigger than that
of Spotify historically about 80% of
music listening is let's someone else
play DJ music listening as opposed to I
play my own DJ I pick my own songs I
build my own playlists and even the
evolution of first Sony Walkman for
those of you remember that - the
evolution of the iPod didn't
fundamentally change that 8020
characteristic so we think this
opportunity need to be in some sense the
next generation of radio in that form of
serendipitous listening is a bigger
opportunity but Spotify may still have a
wonderful opportunity there's important
differences - this gets into kind of the
arcane world of digital music but to the
extent some of you get into the world of
entertainment and median content there
are important lessons here Pandora
operates in the US under a statutory
license a compulsory license we don't
have to go bang the record labels for
licenses let us do business let us you
know do what we want to do we operate
under certain constraints as a result of
that but are able to do our thing and
important they're able to play any
placement piece of music that's ever
been released for public sale anywhere
in the world Spotify on the other hand
and Hulu to some extent is in the same
category is in this kind of endless loop
of negotiating deals with rights holders
and if you do just even kind of a
classic the old-fashioned kind of Five
Forces analysis of a business the the
rights holders the content holders have
very powerful
voices in the Spotify kind of model in
the Hulu kind of model and they have
less power
not none they have considerable power
less power in ours because of the
statutory nature of of radio licensing
so we like that aspect as a business we
also like the fact that the way we
deliver the music it makes sense to use
in the car it makes sense to use in a
bunch of locations where maybe Spotify
is a little bit harder to figure out how
you use it in the car but anyway we're
not hell-bent on beating Spotify we we
want to displace the 200 million people
who listen to FM radio today and give
him something a lot better I'm sorry oh
he's got the mic problems I didn't know
that sorry uh I was just wondering um if
you could say something about the
culture at Pandora and as a kind of
internet startup company that really
took advantage of new opportunities in
the next five years how do you see
taking advantage of new opportunities or
dealing with new challenges kind of in a
forward-thinking way now that you've
achieved a relatively stable you know
existence and offering how do you move
forward and continue to be someone who
proposes new new things to people it's a
it's a great it's a great question and I
could probably talk I can give you the
whole kind of 40 minute thing on culture
I'm really passionate about it but I let
me just talk about one aspect in
particular that I think's been been the
life-or-death good for us and I'm a deep
deep believer that we built this company
starting with Tim the founder and then
those of us who kind of joined with him
seven years ago with a tremendous focus
on a purpose that virtually every
employee could hook into and what our
vision is what our purpose we wrap
ourselves
around is is is taking all of the great
music that's been created in the world
and connecting with all the people who
who would enjoy that
that that music and although that's a
very simple kind of concept it's deeply
resonant for us both as people who love
enjoy me and listening to music but in
many ways even more deeply because so
many of the people accompany create
music either professionally or various
degrees of amateur musicians and really
understand at a kind of deeply emotional
level how hard it is for people who
create music to find their audience
the story of Pandora starts with Tim
Westergren just out of Stanford
undergrad climbing into a van with his
bandmates and spending the next 10 years
trying to make it as rock stars
literally what Tim tried to do for for
10 years and back in his day what that
meant was you rolled the van into
Boulder Colorado you look for some bolt
and boards and telephone poles and
you've tack up a placard that says
yellow wood Junction that was the name
of the band that won't win a trivia
contest someday is playing at
such-and-such bar and you hope that
maybe 10 or 15 people catch those
bulletin board posters telephone pole
posters and that is how bands
historically started in this country and
built their audience kind of created
what they thought was great music and
then worked unbelievably hard through
the most inefficient of all processes to
connect with people who might enjoy that
music and all of us hook in to this
concept then it can be so much better
and to the benefit of those who create
music and to the benefit of those who
enjoy music and what's the punchline of
this and why is it so vital to Pandora
so the truth is Pandora was was
essentially technically bankrupt twice
in its history in 2002 and 2003 the
company which had been started
at the very end of the the big bubble
was started in January of 2000 ran out
of funding and had no opportunity to get
funds in 2002 and 2003 it wasn't running
on fumes the fumes were gone there was a
Renta Fiction from the landlord and yet
a core group of 30 people continued to
move things forward continued to build
the music genome continued to advance
the technology and eventually got things
far enough where in April of 2004 the
company can get another round of funding
as we went through the incredible
royalty fight that we went through
several years ago it was a somewhat
similar experience and the punchline of
all this is young companies go through
really really hard times we may have
been through harder times than I hope
any of you experienced but we've been
near death twice in our existence and
the fact that the company was always
built on this with this deep sense of
purpose and we worked hard and we
continue to work hard to share that with
employees enabled us to get through it
as opposed to if you start a company and
it's somewhat tempting I'm an MBA many
people here in this room say I have a
concept and it's a very kind of
mercenary left-brain Mbah kind of
approach to the business if it lacks
that real emotion that real tremendous
sense of purpose I think you can have a
much harder time attracting motivating
and keeping people through the hard time
so really long-winded answer your
question but one aspect of culture that
has been tremendously vital for us
thanks for your patience so when we were
talking about movies at the beginning
and then I guess ebooks I'm
fundamentally talking about the
technological advance in sort of
distribution affecting the creative
process how do you think that plays out
in music how does the way that you
distribute music to people effect I
guess what and how people make music I
think that's a fabulous question and I
think there's really interesting work
that's going on in terms of if you take
these principles
you see you know leading-edge folks like
Trent Reznor who actually got an Oscar
for the Facebook soundtrack many of you
may know him much more as the frontman
for Nine Inch Nails but Reznor released
an album I don't know two three years
ago now where in some sense he released
it in its traditional form but he also
released it so that you could take all
of the individual tracks the sub tracks
that make up the recording in GarageBand
and remix and do pretty much anything
you wanted to it and that's you know
that would be an example of a musician
embracing the co-creation opportunity
kind of moving from this model where I
as the Creator do all the creating and
you as the consumer just do the
consuming and in some sense that would
be the analogy no to my story of the the
book that's actually dynamic and that
the the reader co creates the ending or
whatever I don't know and so there are
people who you know leading-edge people
like Trent Reznor who I think have done
that in in music and I think it's pretty
interesting
I still think you know the vast vast
majority of music today is created the
same way that it's been before so I'd
actually probably put this in the
category of still untapped opportunity
but I think it's a I think it's a pretty
rich opportunity particularly you know
as a being we think a lot about new and
emerging artists and you know typically
the fan base of a new emerging artists
it's very passionate and variant of the
music and I I think maybe it's the
marketer in me the opportunity for the
artists to kind of reach out and say hey
be be part of this not just in a sense
of buy my CDs or come to my concerts or
merged but actually in some more
fundamental artistic way be part of it I
think is pretty interesting
oh we got a mic in here so I've learned
to follow the mic so so what's the
rationale for the record labels charging
a higher royalty fee to online radio
than to traditional radio and do you
think isn't there maybe like an
antitrust aspect to that it's the
question oh I guess everyone heard the
question cuz I'm like it's actually in
the record labels would be more than
happy to charge traditional radio the
same thing they charge Oz it's actually
a legal problem in this country this
country is actually pretty screwed up in
terms of how it treats the different
forms of radio and believe it or not
when when a song plays on am/fm radio in
this country the artist who performs it
and their label if they're working with
label get no compensation at all and the
vast vast majority of the world when to
use the Lady Gaga example when her new
song plays on radio in the UK she gets
compensated for that for that play along
with universal I think it's her label US
law actually gives a man FM a free pass
in terms of compensating performing
artists and labels we think that's wrong
we think it's wrong in part because it's
not a level playing field and it's
unfair to us but actually reflecting the
the deep musicianship culture that we
have we think it's just wrong because
musicians should be compensated for
their work that's a fundamental
principle of ours so someday we may ask
you to write your congressperson and
help us fix that
so I'm really fascinated by your bio and
just you know alone Saturn Pandora and I
sit on the board of a number of
Technology venture-backed companies and
so my question is what is it about your
DNA or your skills that are your
training that has enabled you to be
effective across such you know just very
different sectors and a related question
how can I identify that gene or skillset
when I'm interviewing executives because
I often find that I'm in a situation
where I need to hire a c-level executive
but the skillset doesn't necessarily
exist in the sector because we're in a
space of innovation so I need to find
someone from another sector to pull them
in to then deploy that into a new sector
but it's really hard to tease that out
of someone's resume and backgrounds so
tell me what's the secret and how do I
find other people like you that's a
really tough question the first part of
your question can be rephrased as you
know your background Joe makes no sense
at all explain thyself as it happens
right although I happen to be a CEO
today was more recently president Elon
at heart I'm a consumer marketer and and
you know out of Business School my
passion was really around consumer
marketing but very specifically I wrap
myself around those consumer marketing
opportunities were you could really do
something game-changing for the consumer
kind of transformative of an industry
where the consumer was deeply involved
and in some sense to do the first
parallel from Saturn trying to
revolutionising what it's like to shop
for and own and get serviced a car the
connection to Elon was the lending
process sucks every bit as much as the
car buying process and the founders of
Elon were interested in me in the VCS
Bob Kegel and IRA Aaron price were
interested in me because they saw an
analogy between a transfer
car-buying transforming lending and I
saw the analogy and then it fit you know
hey that's pretty interesting to take
something consumers really hate getting
a loan and can we use the power of the
Internet to make it more transparent and
a better experience and then when I met
up with Tim I saw not a category where
people hate musics a category people
love but I very much hooked into hey
digital music creates the opportunity to
really transform what it's like to
listen to music from a consumer
standpoint so that's my own DNA for what
it's worth
how do you find that I'm not a hundred
percent I'm not a hundred percent Shore
maybe it's the maybe it's somewhat
related to the question I answered
before in the sense of for all my left
brain MB anus
I am also driven by this deep passion
for certain kinds of things that I like
to do and maybe part of the secret and
your job is to to uncover exactly what
people's passions are and does it really
fit the the the opportunity that you're
looking at but it's tough other
questions there's got to be you know the
rest of the room without a mic what is
my opinion on how music should be priced
incredibly complicated question if I
were to answer it very conceptually I
think the most important thing is the
the recording industry particularly
which is the sell music part of the the
business I think if you look at it
historically you'd say it never it
missed the the marketing class today
that talked about segmentation because
with very few exceptions even up until
today music was priced kind of one price
you you know an album was priced at X
and maybe they had the concept of new
albums were priced that X plus 20% and
you know the catalog album was priced at
X but I think what and I'll actually use
Trent Reznor's another example there are
lots of people like him I think in the
new world what smart musicians are doing
and smart labels that are working with
smart musicians is adopting a segmented
approach so the album I talked about
with Trent Reznor I simplified it when I
said what he did with that release
because he actually did I think an
online release that was very simple and
very cheap may even been some of the
tracks were free might even you could
get half the album for free or something
like that and then you could get the
whole album just digital form or
something like that for some kind of
price let's just call it $10 but then if
you wanted kind of all of the bells and
whistles the ability to mix the tracks
whatever then there was yet another
price and then all the way up to I think
there was a three digit number on you
could actually get the album and the
notes and everything and pretty much a
you know something for your living room
table something a beautiful book of the
album for $200 and then I think he
actually even had something that for
$5,000 you got the whole album and
everything and you got a backstage pass
the next time he was in town now that
might not be the best example but I
think it illustrates an approach that
says hey there's different audience
here's there's segmentation matters when
it comes to music it's not we have this
generic thing called the CD it is one a
product one SKU and other than the fact
maybe we price it a little higher when
it's new then when it's old it's one
kind of SKU and we don't care at all
about segmentation I think the people
who are going to do the best in the
music business going forward are people
who really embrace embrace segmentation
in a certain sense in it fits a general
phenomenon that my guess is you all have
studied in a sense of freemium I mean
freemium applies to the example I gave
might be called a freemium example but I
I believe the underlying concept of
Premium Pandora is free for most users
but if you want no ads and other
features you pay a fee and there's
certainly other services that are much
more complex in terms of their freemium
structures the foundation of that is
segmentation understanding different
segments what's the right value
proposition what's the point pricing for
those different segments in this
one-to-one unicast world one can take
advantage of smart segmentation much
more than in old world if I were to
defend the old world of the record
labels they just sold their CDs through
you know they wholesale them to to a
small number of record store chains and
maybe it was harder for them to
implement sophisticated segmentation
schemes that's not true that excuse
isn't there anymore so segmentation
consumer insight different value
propositions different pricing I think
applies to a lot of content in today's
world Glu tell me about your views on
the net neutrality and how it's going to
change how Panera Pandora is going to be
priced and what is the impact on
customers like us like I got a 200 MB
plan so sure net neutrality the first
thing I always share on net neutrality
is that in some ways I think it's the
wrong question particularly in this
country in that if you actually look at
the real economics of mobile broadband
wireless which is where the real rub is
even more so in fixed wireless the cost
to deliver a megabyte of data is
unbelievably low so when you think about
your data plan that's $20 or $30 or
whatever the the the actual price not
just variable but fully allocated to
deliver whatever the capacity of that
data plan is whether it's two gigs or
five gigs or whatever people using
there's plenty of revenue in that twenty
or thirty dollar data plan to cover the
costs
of delivering the transport itself and
that cost of transport going down
dramatically and so the real question
actually is how is it that the operators
have any pricing power whatsoever given
that it's a fairly commoditized service
with extremely low level costs and you
can actually see this in certain markets
particularly say the UK even sprint in
the u.s. any time a carrier has excess
capacity
you see discounting you know sprint is
much cheaper than Verizon and AT&T for
the simple reason it has capacity and
the cost structure of the business is
such if you have capacity you want to
fill it and you're willing to cut price
to to do it and so the question we need
to be asking is why is it that in some
times we even need to be worried about
pricing data caps whatever and the
simple answer in this country is the
real issue is spectrum in that relative
to the amount of transport that is being
put on mobile wireless and will be put
on mobile Wireless as all this neat
stuff grows is this country still has in
my view in a lighting a lot of smart
people's view far too much spectrum
taking care of you know old-fashioned
broadcast TV delivery and not enough
spectrum going to wireless so I actually
think the the answer internet neutrality
well we could get in a philosophical
discussion of net neutrality I actually
think the much more pragmatic thing is
we need to get the spectrum lined up to
where it's going to be used because we
might have a net neutrality issue if we
have a spectrum capacity issue in that
if there's not enough spectrum then
somehow the carriers have to figure out
a way to allocate that capacity that's
less than the demand if we solve the
problem fundamentally of getting all of
the capacity in the spectrum the
underlying cost of the system everywhere
where there's excess capacity there's
downward
pricing pressure on mobile broadband and
there's competitive activity like you
see from sprinting in the US like you
see from Hutchinson 3 in the UK so
long-winded way of saying I think the
real issue is spectrum and we need to be
helping the smart people in our
government like Julius Genachowski who
runs the FCC who sees this and is trying
to get the spectrum reallocated from
what made sense 20 years ago when TV was
delivered you know overwhelmingly
through over-the-air to what makes sense
10 years from now when TV is delivered
through IP technology and we lose we use
tons of of wireless spectrum for mobile
data does that make sense
follow-up question is what is what do
you think you as a CEO of startup has
got influence and what it means to a
small entrepreneurs who are trying to
start businesses in these things like we
have absolutely zero power say the last
part again how much of influence you can
do or this institutional reform you're
talking about allocating spectrum onto
the mobile more than the TV and what it
means to the entrepreneurs like can we
loudly start a business and not be
having the danger of getting cut out
because of the pricing war you know I
think everyone should be writing their
congressperson and telling them to
support the FCC in its efforts to get
spectrum allocation rationalized in this
country and you might say well that
nothing ever happens
funny story about Pandora we would be
out of business if people didn't write
and call their Congress people 2 to 3
years ago it's the only reason we stayed
in business and I saw firsthand the real
power of grassroots activity in terms of
being able to move Congress we actually
got two bills passed in Congress you
know there's a saying you know that
would take an act of Congress which is a
code for that would be impossible we got
that done twice in a 12-month period and
we needed it done in order to survive
when we got it
through grassroots activity I'm think we
disclosed that dollar amount and we do
believe that that you know companies
need to be politically active I mean
there are important issues that are
being debated you know in in our
government and in other governments such
as the one I just talked about and I
don't think any of us who are on the
forward edge of technologies in
particular can afford to be silent thank
you all very very much